INFLUENCES FROM ABROAD, AND
OTHER GRIEVANCES.
>>> FEDERAL PROSECUTORS HAVE
GAINED THE SUPPORT OF A KEY
CONFIDANTE IN THEIR SEX
TRAFFICKING INVESTIGATION OF
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ.
ON FRIDAY, JOEL GREENBERG
ADMITTED HE PAID AN UNDERAGE
GIRL TO HAVE SEX WITH HIM AND
OTHER UNIDENTIFIED MEN.
GREENBERG IS EXPECTED TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO SIX FEDERAL CHARGES IN
A FLORIDA COURTROOM NEXT WEEK.
MAJOR GARRETT REPORTS ON WHAT
THIS COULD MEAN FOR GAETZ, A
THREE-TERM REPUBLICAN.
>> Reporter: FLORIDA REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ ONCE
CALLED JOEL GREENBERG HIS WING
MAN.
IN THE PLEA AGREEMENT, GREENBERG
ADMITS TO KNOWINGLY PAYING A
MINOR FOR SEX, AND THE DOCUMENT
SAYS HE INTRODUCED THE MINOR TO
OTHER ADULT MEN WHO ENGAGED IN
COMMERCIAL SEX ACTS WITH THE
MINOR.
MULTIPLE SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH
THE MATTER TELL CBS NEWS ONE OF
THE MEN GREENBERG ABSOLUTESED A
MINOR TO WAS GAETZ, AND THAT
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS ARE
LOOKING INTO WHETHER GAETZ HAD A
SEXUAL RELATIONSHIP WITH HER.
GAETZ HAS REPEATEDLYDEN DENIED
HAVING SEX WITH A MINOR AND
PAYING FOR SEX.
CBS NEWS HAS LEARNED THE
IDENTITY OF THE MINOR IN
QUESTION WHO IS NOW 21.
>> CAN I ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS?
>> Reporter: ON WEDNESDAY AT THE
CAPITOL, WE TRIED TO ASK GAETZ
ABOUT HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
WOMAN.
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ?
ARLO DEVLIN BROWN IS A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
>> IF I HAD DEALINGS WITH JOEL
GREENBERG WHERE I WAS INVOLVED
IN ANY OF THE ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES
HE'S PLED GUILTY TO,
PARTICULARLY SEX TRAFFICKING A
MINOR, I'D BE VERY CONCERNED.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO
MULTIPLE SOURCES, THE WOMAN WHO
WAS BY THEN 18 ALSO TRAVELED TO
THE BAHAMAS IN 2018 WITH GAETZ
AND AT LEAST THREE OTHER PAID
ESCORTS.
GREENBERG IS FACING A MINIMUM
PRISON SENTENCE OF 12 YEARS AND
AGREED TO HELP FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS WITH THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
>> YOU CAN'T HALF COOPERATE ONCE
YOU SIGN UP WITH THE GOVERNMENT
TO BE A COOPERATE.
YOU BETTER PROVIDE FULL AND
COMPLETE AND TRUTHFUL
INFORMATION.
>> Reporter: A SPOKESMAN FOR
GAETZ SAID, QUOTE, CONGRESSMAN
GAETZ DOESN'T SEEM TO BE NAMED
NOR REFERENCED IN MR.
GREENBERG'S PLEA.
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ HAS NEVER HAD
SEX WITH A MINOR AND HAS NEVER
PAID FOR SEX.
JOEL GREENBERG IS SCHEDULED TO
PLEAD GUILTY IN FEDERAL COURT IN
ORLANDO